Una imagen para la historia: por primera vez,
desde que terminaran los combates en 1953,
un líder norcoreano, en este caso, Kim Jong-un,
un despiadado dictador que controla con mano
de hierro Corea del Norte, ha puesto un pie
en Corea del Sur para declarar su supuesta
intención de paz y desnuclearización.
Ahora bien: ¿Es este realmente el momento
de la paz? ¿Qué podemos esperar? ¿Por qué
de repente parece que todo va viento en popa? ¿Está
dispuesta Corea del Norte a renunciar a la
bomba nuclear? Amigos, estas son algunas de
las preguntas que estoy seguro, todos nos
estamos haciendo. Así que… veámoslo.
Tarareando, paseando, cogiendose de la mano,
brindando y cenando juntos. Así es como el
pasado viernes 27 de abril de 2018 pudimos
ver a los líderes de Corea del Norte y Corea del Sur.
Hablamos de la última cumbre intercoreana
en la que los dos países se comprometieron
a buscar un acuerdo de paz definitivo [técnicamente
las dos Coreas continúan en Guerra], a recomponer
sus relaciones y también a perseguir la “desnuclearización” de la península coreana.
La cumbre tuvo lugar en la zona desmilitarizada,
en el poblado de Panmunjom, exactamente el
mismo lugar donde se firmó el armisticio
de la Guerra de Corea.
Tanto el líder norcoreano, Kim Jong-un, como
el presidente de Corea Sur, Moon Jae-in, hicieron
gala de una aparente complicidad que, amigos,
hubiera sido muy, pero que muy difícil de
imaginar hace tan solo unos pocos meses.
Y es que lo cierto es que la jornada dejó
imágenes para la historia.
[No estoy exagerando. Las escenas que vimos
de paseos, apretones de manos y cuchicheos
entre los dos líderes, no hubieran desencajado,
para nada, en el guión de alguna que otra
película romántica.]
Y, ¿sabéis qué? En cierto modo se trataba
precisamente de eso, de un... “cortejo”
político entre dos líderes que no podrían
ser más diferentes.
(Por un lado, el Presidente de Corea del Sur,
Moon Jae-in, un abogado especializado en derechos humanos.
Un hombre de origen humilde cuyos
padres lograron huir de Corea del Norte y
que fue, durante su juventud, un activista
por la democracia.
Por otro lado, Kim Jong-un, uno de los peores
tiranos de todo el planeta. El líder omnipotente
de uno de los países más terribles que podemos
siquiera imaginar. )
Porque, amigos, a pesar de las imágenes de
la cumbre, en la que Kim Jong-un parecía
casi un oso amoroso, no olvidemos quién es
realmente, no olvidemos que el líder norcoreano
dirige con mano de hierro un auténtico régimen
del terror donde las violaciones de los derechos
humanos son parte de las funciones rutinarias
del estado.
(Hemos casi olvidado las alegaciones de que
habría matado a su propio hermano con armas
químicas justo el año pasado y que hizo
trizas a su tío con un cañón antiaéreo.”
Gary Samore, Miembro del Consejo
de Seguridad Nacional del Presidente Barack Obama.)
A pesar de ello, y gracias a las imágenes
que vimos y a la declaración acordada por los
dos gobiernos, la mayor parte de la prensa
no tardó en calificar este encuentro como
una “jornada histórica”, como el día
en que de una vez por todas triunfó la paz.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
¿Realmente las cosas van tan bien? o dicho
de otro modo, ¿estamos ante un ejercicio
sincero o ante una gran operación de Marketing?
¿Ha cambiado la hoja de ruta de Pyongyang?
(“El diálogo es ciertamente mejor que una
marcha a la guerra. Dicho eso, todos debemos
mantener nuestras expectativas bajo control.
Wendy R. Sherman, subsecretaria de Estado
para asuntos políticos de 2011 a 2015 y coordinadora
de políticas de Corea del Norte en la administración
Clinton.)
Lo vamos a ver, pero antes tenemos que responder
a una pregunta, que seguro muchos nos hemos hecho:
¿Cómo diantres hemos pasado en tan solo
unos pocos meses de escuchar tambores de guerra
a un encuentro… tan… como decirlo… tan
cordial, tan armonioso?
Pues bien, amigos, podemos encontrar 3 explicaciones
diferentes... pero al mismo tiempo complementarias,
al nuevo “comportamiento” del régimen
de Corea del Norte; que ha pasado en poco
tiempo de amenazar a los Estados Unidos a
suspender sus pruebas nucleares y de misiles.
(1/10/2017: “Corea del Norte amenaza con
convertir a EE.UU. en un «mar de llamas»” ABC)
(20/04/2018: “Corea del Norte suspende sus
pruebas nucleares y de misiles” CNN)
Pues bien, veamos las posibles causas de
este cambio. Y, ojo, ya os adelanto que las
cosas no son tan simples como parecen. Atentos.
1.PYONGYANG, TENEMOS UN PROBLEMA
Primera explicación posible.
Según varios analistas de Estados Unidos, Corea
del Sur, y dos estudios de investigadores
chinos, el centro de pruebas nucleares de
Punggye-RI, situado en el corazón de una
montaña de 2.200 metros de altura conocida
como la montaña Mantap, podría haberse derrumbado
tras la última prueba atómica con una bomba
termonuclear de 250 kilotones que Corea del Norte
detonó en este lugar el pasado 3 de
septiembre de 2017.
Una explosión tan fuerte que provocó un
terremoto de grado 6,3 en la escala Richter.
Pues bien, el derrumbe parece un hecho confirmado,
lo que no está claro es si el centro está
todavía operativo o no.
("Basándonos en la severidad del estallido
inicial, los temblores posteriores a la prueba
y el alcance de las alteraciones observables
en la superficie, debemos suponer que debe
de haber habido un daño sustancial a la red
de túneles existente bajo la montaña Mantap".
Frank V. Pabian y Jack Liu.)
De no ser operativo o haber quedado muy dañado
al régimen podría llevarle tiempo reconstruir
este lugar para poder albergar nuevas pruebas
de forma “segura”.
Lo que en cierto modo podría haber acelerado
los plazos para el anuncio de suspensión
de nuevas pruebas.
Dicho esto, en cualquier caso este sería
un factor que podría haber alterado los plazos…
pero no… no parece que esta pueda ser la
causa principal del cambio de discurso.
2. ES LA ECONOMÍA, ESTÚPIDO
Otra hipótesis, tiene que ver con el efecto
de las sanciones internacionales sobre la
economía norcoreana.
Cómo todos sabéis, Corea del Norte es un
país muy pero que muy pobre.
Pues bien, durante años gran parte
de la comunidad internacional ha impuesto
sanciones sobre Corea del Norte… pero en
general estas no han afectado a los principales
socios de este país: China, Rusia, Vietnam…
(Sin embargo todo esto empezó a cambiar con
las sanciones que Naciones Unidas comenzó
a imponer a Corea del Norte en 2017 como respuesta
a las pruebas nucleares.
Por primera vez estas sanciones fueron cumplidas
en gran medida por China… y eso, amigos,
es un duro golpe para este país. La inmensa
mayor parte del comercio norcoreano se produce
con China y si eso se corta… pues… en
Pyongyang tienen un problema muy serio.)
Un problema, amigos, que se multiplicó cuando
en septiembre, tras la última prueba nuclear,
el Consejo de Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas
prohibió todas las exportaciones clave de
Corea del Norte, incluyendo carbón, hierro,
textiles…
Y no solo eso, en diciembre este mismo órgano
acordó limitar las importaciones de petróleo
refinado a medio millón de barriles al año,
una reducción del 90% respecto a las compras
de petróleo refinado de Corea del Norte el
año anterior.
¿El resultado de todo esto? Pues, muchas
fábricas han tenido que cerrar por falta
de materias primas y el ejército ante la
falta de gasolina ha tenido que recurrir a
motores de carbón e incluso a carros de bueyes.
Tal como lo escucháis.
(Y aunque pueda resultar sorprendente… esta
situación no solo acentúa la debilidad de
Corea del Norte, sino que además es un duro
golpe para el gobierno de Kim Jong Un que
ha situado como una prioridad el desarrollo
económico.
Y… claro, las sanciones ponen en jaque el
nivel de vida de las élites y también de
la incipiente clase media…)
[Un momento, ¿incipiente clase media en Corea
del Norte? Pues sí… lo habéis escuchado bien.
De hecho os hago una pregunta, ¿Creeis que
puede estar desarrollándose un mercado capitalista
dentro de la actual Corea del Norte? Pues…
estate atento a nuestros próximos vídeos.]
Pero… aunque todo esto es importante y seguro
ha influido… tampoco parece algo que pueda
poner en riesgo al régimen, no al menos de
momento.
("Si usted piensa que los norcoreanos se revelarán
o el régimen se derrumbará debido a las
sanciones, usted no sabe nada acerca de los
norcoreanos. Éstas son personas que sobrevivieron
a la hambruna comiendo malezas”. Kang mi-Jin,
un desertor norcoreano que trabaja para el
Banco Central de Corea del Sur.)
Así que… amigos, entonces ¿Por qué ha
cambiado tanto Pyongyang su discurso? O..
¿es que realmente no ha cambiado nada? Atentos.
3.OBJETIVO CUMPLIDO
Corea del Norte es una potencia nuclear, esto
es un hecho.
Según la inteligencia norteamericana este
país podría disponer actualmente de entre
20 y 60 ojivas listas para ser usadas.
Es decir, dicho de otro modo. Pyongyang ya
ha conseguido su gran objetivo, su seguro
de vida, el mejor instrumento de disuasión
jamás construido por el hombre.
Es verdad, en la cumbre intercoreana del pasado
viernes 27 de abril Corea del Norte prometió
implicarse en la desnuclearización de la
península… pero un momento… porque eso
no implica que esté dispuesto a renunciar
a sus armas nucleares.
Primero, porque Corea del Norte ya ha prometido
muchas cosas que luego ha imcumplido.
Las negociaciones y acuerdos de 1991, 1994,
2000, 2007, 2012... las promesas norcoreanas
no son algo nuevo y hasta ahora siempre se
han quedado... en papel mojado.
(En 1994, el padre de Kim Jong Un, Kim Jong
Il llegó incluso a poner en marcha el desmantelamiento
del programa nuclear y permitió que inspectores
internacionales visitaran el país para comprobar
el proceso. Todo a cambio de una generosa
ayuda de Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo años después se supo que todo
fue una farsa, el programa continuó su desarrollo
de forma clandestina.)
En el año 2000, el presidente surcoreano Kim Dae-jung anunció que
un nuevo día iba a llegar tras volver de visitar a Kim Jong-il en Pyonyang.
En el año 2007 el presidente surcoreano Roh Moo-hyun afirmó que durante su visita a Corea del Norte
que Kim Jong-il tenía una firme intención de restablecer la paz.)
Y Segundo, porque no entendemos lo mismo por
desnuclearización.
Veréis, para Pyongyang este término tiene
mucho que ver también con las capacidades
militares de Estados Unidos en la península
y en la región.
Y en cualquier caso parece muy difícil que
Kim Jong-un esté dispuesto a desprenderse
de su mejor seguro de vida.
("Kim sigue siendo la misma persona que fue
cuando purgó a potenciales rivales, encarceló
a miles de su gente, y mató a sus parientes.
Este es un momento de esperanza, pero la extrema
precaución está bien justificada”. Abraham
Denmark, Director del programa Asia del Centro
Wilson.)
De hecho, y esto es algo que muestran las comunicaciones
norcoreanas que han sido interceptadas, todo
parece formar parte de una especie de hoja
de ruta:
Primero, el régimen tiene que garantizar
su supervivencia, algo que ha conseguido con
su arsenal nuclear.
Y segundo, negociar con la comunidad internacional
para poner fin a las sanciones y poder poner
en marcha un programa de reformas que pueda
atraer inversiones de China y Corea del Sur.
Es decir, lejos de lo que podría parecernos
en un primer momento, Pyongyang podría estar
siguiendo, simplemente, el plan trazado.
[¿Fue la cumbre intercoreana un gran ejercicio
de Marketing?]
Esto en cierto modo es lo que explica el escepticismo
con el que la mayoría de los surcoreanos
viven las promesas del norte. Atentos a esta
encuesta:
Pero, ahora, turno para ti, ¿Crees que Corea
del Norte renunciará a su programa nuclear?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Y como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y suscribete a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.